Warren Buffett said that the difference
between really successful people and the
most successful people this is me
paraphrasing is that the most successful
people say no to almost everything I've
tried to take that because it's so hard
I had chiropractor agency I had a dental
agency I had five gym locations I had a
gym launch business where we did turn
rounds I had all of those things going
on and there was no CEO besides me and I
also made no actually I mean I made
money from all of them but no income
like everything was just enough to break
even it was nine spinning plates and
it's because like I was so opportunistic
and it's very classic new entrepreneur
to just say yes to everything it's so
simple and so hard which a lot of
success habits are the quote from John
Maxwell which I absolutely adore that
says you cannot overestimate the
unimportance of practically everything
Greg mcewen's essentialism is one of my
top five books of all time and it's for
this precise reason that it's an
antidote to the type A Fallout I can do
it all I will do it all watch me suffer
and bear this burden you can do the hard
work thing but the working hard and
being spread thin are two different
Dynamics